[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
من الرياضات النفسيه المحببه عند العرب
قديما وحديثا لقطه الفقع فنزول المطر في
موسمه وتتابع نزول المطر وان تكون الارض
سريحه لم يعبث بها انسان ولم يطعها حيوان
اذا توافرت هذه الشروط فان الفقع يطلع
فنزول المطر بموسم سهيل والوسم يطلع لنا
الفقع زبيدي وهو الفقع الابيض البارز على
الارض واذا نزل موسم المربعانيه فانه يطلع
لنا الفك على الاخلاسي وهو الفقع الاحمر
المندس على الارض واشهر انواع الفقع
الزبيدي واطعمها اخلاسي وهنا الاولين الله
يرحمهم يقولون الاخلاصي الراسي والزبيدي
الوليدي ام البنات تراه هم اللي يقولونه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وظهور الفقع دليل قاطع على بدايه دفء باطن
الارض فالفقع يظل محتبسا في باطنها طوال
فتره الشتاء القارص ومع بدايه شمس الربيع
فانه يظهر على وجه الارض وتباشير الفجع
المسمى بالهوبر يظهر بعد اول مطره باربعين
ليله والفقع صالح للاكل يظهر بعد اول مطره
ب 70 ليله والفقع فطر والاكثار منه مضر
على باطنيه الانسان ولهذا العام هيقولون
لا طلع الفجر
[موسيقى]